good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight what's interesting about
so many of the people you see talking on
television is not just that they tell
you things that they know are not true
they do they lie regularly and they
shade the truth even more than that you
of course knew that it's obvious what's
amazing is how they do it in unison one
will say something false and then within
what seems like minutes all the others
are saying it to the exact same thing
sometimes word-for-word it's like
they're all texting each other in
commercial breaks or maybe they just
know instinctively what the latest
Democratic Party talking points will be
we could give you endless examples of
this but here's the most recent one in
the day since last week's midterm
elections all the geniuses on cable have
simultaneously decided that the migrant
caravan marching toward the United
States is a mirage it's not real it
never has been real it was always a fake
threat created by unscrupulous
right-wing politicians to win the last
election watch them sing that tune in
perfect harmony
this was never an urgent issue these
people were a thousand plus miles away
from the border to also further your
point if you are so concerned about
invaders and very bad people wouldn't
you be on the border today instead of
your Secretary of Defense they've been
running on an imaginary Caravan the
president talked a lot he could stop
talking about the so-called Caravan
heading toward the border this stupid
caravan you know it's a lie that this
Caravan is a problem of that magnitude
the so-called caravan the imaginary
caravan that's what Jeff Zucker told
them to say too bad we now have pictures
reality is the enemy of propaganda and
the reality on our southern border
tonight is that a large number of
migrants from that Caravan are now
massed just south of San Diego and
they're trying to get into this country
in the meantime those same people are
overwhelming city services in Tijuana
and causing a crisis there the people
from the caravan are doing all of this
because the act
we exist they are a physical reality no
matter what they're telling you one CNN
well apparently nobody has alerted
California senator Kamala Harris
she believes that anyone worried about
illegal immigration must be a dangerous
racist and that's why she just compared
federal law enforcement officers to the
Ku Klux Klan plan was a what we would
call today a domestic terrorist group
why why why would we call them domestic
terrorist group because they tried to
use fear and force to change political
environment and what was the motivation
for the use of fear and force based on
race and ethnicity right are you aware
of the perception of many about how the
the the power and the discretion at ice
is being used to enforce the laws and do
you see any parallels I do not see any
parallels between I'm talking about
possessors and agents I'm talking about
perception I do not see a parallel are
you aware that there's the perceptions
we know are you aware that there's an
ice in the same category as the KKK
American citizens trying to protect
their country's borders upholding laws
passed by our democratically elected
Congress are somehow like the KKK it
seems like an especially stupid and
vicious thing to say it's cruel really
how would you feel if you were a nice
officer or your brother was can you
imagine throwing out that kind of
slander at your fellow Americans just
for doing their jobs you'd have to be an
awfully self-righteous person to talk
like that
Harris is so we're a lot of them listen
to senator sherrod Brown of Ohio a man
who advocates for unrestricted late term
abortion explain that he's on jesus's
team and you aren't jesus said when i
was hungry you fed me when i was thirsty
he gave me drink when I was a stranger
you welcomed me what you did for those
who seemed less important you did for me
not the least of these it's just society
may may act like they're less important
but we don't because we we understand
the value of people we understand the
dignity of work we understand the values
of this country stands for we understand
the value of little
people senator Brown says really do you
how about the millions of American
workers whose wages haven't risen in
decades thanks in part to mass
immigration or how by the way since
we've run the topic how about the people
of Tijuana
the caravan came north because they knew
they'd have a shot of getting into this
country Democrats told them that they
encouraged this whole thing from the
very first day now it's a disaster the
mayor of Tijuana says his city is
buckling under the weight of the
migrants many of them are criminals the
mayor of Tijuana says violence is broken
out people have been hurt
dozens of migrants never even made it to
the border by the way they are still
missing presumably kidnapped by drug
cartels the human cost has been very
high Democrats are not talking about
that cost somehow it's not interesting
to them won't win them elections we'd
like to talk about it though that's why
we invited Chris Hahn on he's an
attorney radio host and former aide to
Senator Chuck Schumer he joins us
tonight so Chris before we even get to
all that sherrod Brown from Ohio who's
been endorsed by narrow by the way is
lecturing us on Jesus do you think
shared Browns a little bit closer to
Jesus than say I am
well Matthew 25 applies here don't you
think I mean that's what he was quoting
we have people who are fleeing for their
lives who were in desperate need who
want to come to this country and seek
asylum legally by the way by presenting
themselves at the border and we are
sending troops and by the way we're
sending troops to Texas when they're
coming in in San Diego to the trips let
me just if you could address my question
though I mean is that the new standard
you think it's a fair standard this is
not something that I have introduced
into this this is senator sherrod Brown
of Ohio is lecturing us about how he's
on jesus's team and we're not is that a
fair form of political discourse is this
a theocracy just assess what Jesus would
do first no I think we're pointing out
the hypocrisy on the right that like
explain that they are Christians yet
they ignore the teachings of Christ
exactly 25 clearly Kasich sus tangos
they're hypocrites so people who don't
believe in God get some Christians what
it is to be a Christian so let me just
ask you which which politicians would
you say right now on the right are
invoking Jesus when they talk about
building a wall what exact
are you talking about Mike Pence how
about every single day everything he
does every time Mike Pence talks he
invokes Christ every single time so give
me more time every time just just one
example every time he's ever given tell
me about the convention the first thing
he said at the convention was I'm a
Christian a father and a conservative in
some keys afresh Mike Pence says so if
he's really a Christian he should be
practicing what Jesus taught and man you
think that Jesus would not do it Jesus
would have open borders is that what
you're saying I mean is it I guess the
little when I was a little bunny I'm
aware of the verse where the first yeah
but you're comfortable with this is what
you're saying I don't know let me tell
you you are aware of it but I don't know
that you believe it if that's what it
that's what it says Tucker do you see
yourself hence pretends to acknowledge
but he doesn't I'm trying not to end
this interview right now because I'm
getting offended I wonder if you
understand the extent to which you're
playing with fire introducing religious
faith appropriating someone else's
religious face but by the way into a
conversation about public policy do you
think that's a wise thing to do do you
think if Mike Pence got up and said I'm
for building a wall and I'm quoting this
scripture to justify it I know for a
fact that I would say whoa settle down
there's a public policy question
it's a multi-ethnic multi-religious
country don't start doing that it's not
a theocracy but you're saying that now
that that's okay here's the thing one I
didn't mean to offend you on religious
grounds I come on Jesus a team and
you're not like what is that I hear you
I hear you I hear you
I'm just pointing out that many on the
right have taken Christ up as their
banner of how they want to govern and
yet when it comes to doing something
like this they ignore the teachings of
Christ I do not think that religion or
or or scripture should be the basis of
our governance in the minutes okay
separation or late term abortion isn't
it lecturing me on Jesus well look let
me ask you this do you think ins also
since I guess everything's allowed no it
doesn't matter like whatever it takes to
get what we want is it okay to compare
federal law enforcement officials to the
KKK as senator Harris did yes
look I watch I watched that whole clip
Tucker and frankly she was not comparing
them to the KKK she was suggesting to
the nominee that there is a perception
among some it even said probably
wrongfully that there are people out
there why do you get it gonna correct
the percentages so I guess I get it
cause there look I mean a lot of
Hitler's closest staff wore blue ties
I'm not calling you a Nazi I'm saying a
lot of people think you are and now that
I've raised it and linked you to the
Nazis what's your response I mean no
she's comparing federal law enforcement
officials to the Klan and I just wonder
like is there a limit to what you can
say in public if you're a US senator
before you drive the country into some
kind of internal conflict like can you
really say looks like that now you
should not you should not you should not
compare our law enforcement people to
the plan and that is not what she was
doing she was asking she was engaging in
a conversation with somebody who was
seeking to run ice on how he would
change the perception among some people
in this country that they should fear
ice in the city you have is there is
there is there a mrs. Olin but Howard
Kamla Harris who's lived in rich
personal world's her entire life how
exactly would she like how would she
know this does she have some polls she's
going to people think that Isis like the
Klan I think she know she's trying to
impugn that he heard his personal
integrity of people serving the country
on the board like what is this
the client has heard from constituents
she's heard from groups that represent
people who are fearful of ice in her in
her State I'm sure she's trying to
correct that fear because service
Senator Harris is a very sensible person
and I know just thank you just being
with the Klan really shooting them of
anywhere she is I think she's totally
irresponsible I want her to be
responsible she could be president
finally is it time to concede that the
caravan is real and that their
overwhelming Tijuana the mayor of
Tijuana says that a lot of members of
the caravan are violent criminals and
he's afraid of them is he a racist do
you think it sounds like he might be
nobody said it wasn't real they said it
wasn't a real threat and the mayor
Tijuana sounds like a platinum racist
maybe a Klansman do you think he is
president's own generals acknowledged
that this is not a real
threat to our national security wanna
says it's a threat to him well hold on
wait I mean I'm wondering what would
Jesus be okay with what the mayor of
Tijuana has said is he a racist he said
he's a violent criminal is he is Tijuana
analogous to the United States of
America - Tijuana sounds of Katya Juana
has a lot less resources than the United
States of America we have so he gets to
be a big I guess then there are police
officers in Tijuana I'm worried I think
Jesus would be very upset about the
mayor of Tijuana I'm just throwing about
that I'm gonna call sherrod Brown about
it after this Father Brown maybe I'll
see him on Sunday preaching from the
pulpit look Chris great thank you